well now this while the prosecution case
implodes the media is scrambling to make
it all about ridden house white
privilege today cnn published an op-ed
title what kyle rittenhouse tears reveal
about america it reads quote the baby
face vigilante has become a hero to many
among the far right-wing political
establishment circumstances of his tribe
reflect the way in which race shapes
america in an equal criminal justice
system and then of course there's don
lemon
imagine
if
kyle rittenhouse was an 18 or 17 year
old black kid well that's a different
issue with a gun and talk about that
right how would people feel how would
the judge treat him or what about the
people on the right who are making kyle
rittenhouse out to be a choir boy
because he went across state lines
inserted himself into a situation where
he that he had nothing to do with killed
two people and injured another person
how would america feel about
that sonny johnson host of the did she
say that podcast and she joins me now
sonny uh he said what he said so i'm
gonna just let you respond
well we can always expect to laugh we
know exactly what they're going to do so
it's no surprise to see
how they're responding in this
especially there's not any black people
in the case but yet they still find a
way to make it about white supremacy but
what we need to do i think on the right
is to understand the idea the difference
between identity politics and
conservatism equally applied because
what they want to bring out is the idea
of vigilantism and how we should be
against that as a principle well what
they have done is take the idea of intel
vigilantism and replaced it with what we
know to be self-defense and i'm not
saying it's just specifically for this
case i'm talking about overall in black
communities everywhere across the
country how many times can you talk to
people where if you actually listened to
the case and just heard what happened
you would definitely say it was a matter
of self defense and but instead they are
charged by these prosecutors and judges
and then they are sentenced and we do
not get that kind of reprieve where we
can actually question the legislation
and regulation that went into taking
away our ability to protect ourselves
and the most prevalent way you see this
is what they've done with gun control
but they have manifested it in numerous
different ways where they are able to
charge us for basically just wanting to
be defenders of our own lives and now
you i think a lot of conservatives or
republicans are getting to see that play
out across
this trial but just know this isn't a
new thing this is why you have so many
black people complaining about criminal
justice reform and saying that something
needs to be done and this is our moment
to actually have that conversation what
is the difference between vigilantism
and self-defense and how many people in
the black community are actually asking
for the ability to defend their own
selves and communities not being
vigilantes but are um are struck and
down from doing so and i think you will
find that a lot of especially black men
who want to be leaders and stewards in
their communities are thoroughly
punished if they actually step in and
and take those roles seriously because
in progressive areas the uh
responsibilities is supposed to fall on
the government not on us individuals to
actually protect and defend ourselves so
let's go deep in this sonny because
you're exactly right as usual
when i go to communities every single
day and i'm talking about the crime
that's happening there i have been
encouraging the brothers to pick up arms
and you can see it in the numbers where
black ownership is at a record high not
just black men but women as well
these men and women are protecting their
community so if i was to
go along with what the liberals are
saying right now those brothers and
sisters that go out and patrol their
neighborhood if they have to defend
themselves you want them to go on trial
for protecting their community when
there's been bloodshed every single day
what are they to do
they
they will be the ones that go on trial
where you see um they are letting the
criminals out the ones that actually
defend they will be the ones that are
actually charged and faced to go on
trial this is what we have to understand
they are punishing
not simply on color but on ideology so
if you walk in and you say it is my it
is my right to defend myself
they are looking at you like no it is
not it is government's job to defend you
and you need to get in order with that
and that is how we are being handled
like we're children meant to be managed
as opposed to adult american citizens
that should have the ability to not only
protect ourselves our property but our
communities and now you see our
communities falling apart at the seams
and we're supposed to still sit and wait
for government to come and solve it and
anytime we step in to be the forebearers
of change we're the ones that look that
are looked at as the enemies because
we're supposed to leave that job to
government and i think that
conservatives are really missing the
opportunity to have a real conversation
about our ideology and how it intercedes
into crosses with black america as
opposed to continuously being pushed
into these um identity politics uh
conversations that get us nowhere and
solve no problems see the left they have
a we know their agenda they want to gas
ladders they put don lemon on air they
they release these tweets and they make
it very personal they try to do but
there's a message in what you just said
there sonny
yes and the message has to be
conservatism will work in black america
it can be sold it can be packaged in
black and towards black america but what
is not going to work is identity
politics so as long as we are allowing
the left to push us in to that parallel
conversation instead of actually focus
on our ideas and what we believe in
we're not going to find that kindred
relationship with black america that we
should be building and it has to come
local and it has to look at the
regulation and legislation and actually
solve the problems and that's the only
way we're going to fix it and identity
politics is not going to do that 100
sunday johnson you can catch her
tomorrow sirius xm patriot thanks so
much sonny hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else